>>Teacher: Boss Level is this
unique space because it kind
of like takes what we
normally do, it condenses it
into this smaller package,
but it's like amplified.
So during Boss Level, kids are met
with these challenges, multiple,
multiple challenges every day.
>>Student: For my Boss
Level I did with Kate is
that I went to the MOMA with her.
In that Boss Level, I was
able to prove my talent.
>>Teacher: On three,
Bruce, say "Go Boss Level."
Ready, one, two, three...
>>All: Go Boss Level.
>>Teacher: I think if kids really
recognize what their teachers want
to teach them and want to expose them
to, that the sky's the limit in terms
of what their future can hold.
With Boss Level, I feel like the
teacher's really able to pick a topic
that they are passionate
about and then use
that passion to inspire the students.
And because you have such a long
period of time to work on a project,
it feels more satisfying
than even playing a game
for two periods or two lessons.
Like you're really spending five or
six periods a day with the same group
of kids, really pushing them
towards this challenging goal
and it allows the students to
really embody what an artist does
or what a scientist
does or a fundraiser.
And so that really is
a special experience.
The students have to embody
the role of that individual
to get to the end results.
As opposed to, as a student, the end
result is prescribed by the teacher
and defined by the teacher.
They have to define the
end result for themselves.
>>Student: Boss Level is like
where you get to show what you know
from the past trimesters that you've
learned from your teachers and see
if you can show that you
improved from the past months.
>>Teacher: I think it's important for
the kids to be at MOMA first of all
to be in the space and be two feet
in front of a Jackson Pollock.
Like that's a sensory experience
that's really important.
>>Teacher: The idea of learning
by doing is so important
because we really believe
that in order for students
to really understand something, like
to really deeply learn something,
you have to do something with it.
So it's not just about
learning something,
but it's about taking the information
and creating something out of it,
or making something out of it.
And so that kind of learning is
not limited to a classroom space,
but it also happens
in a classroom space.
>>Student: In MOMA, you can only look
at the art and you can't touch it,
or you'll get in trouble.
So we wanted to give
people the opportunity
to touch and feel the art.
>>Student: Okay, what should it be?
I was thinking it would
be called Spa.
We're going to walk them through it
and then they're going
to say what they feel.
Let's say they feel rocks,
but it's actually dirt,
we write down what we think and
then we show them the sheet of paper
of all the things they touched.
>>Woman: Ew!
>>Student: Don't kill it.
>>Woman: Is it bagels?
>>Student: Yeah.
[laughs]
>>Student: I think
embodied learning means
that like you learn
but with your senses.
So like touch, feel, look, and yeah.
>>Teacher: Because you're not
in a classroom, what you expect
to happen can be totally open.
It lets you access your creativity
in a way that's different from being
in a place that you're always in.
>>Teacher: He keeps saying,
"Oh it's fine, it's fine."
>>Student: No, it's fine.
>>Teacher: Really, I don't know,
I don't think I believe you.
I think there's a catch here, because
there's been a catch in all of these.
>>Teacher: My students can always
count on me to support them
in being successful in life,
not just in seventh grade.
And for their future
lives, not just a state test
or some sort of end assessment.
I want them to feel like they can
achieve whatever goal they want
to achieve and I'll always
support them in that.
And I think sometimes holding them
to high standards, which can seem
like being a strict
teacher, is actually sort
of helping them in the long run.
And I think it takes--
for my students, I think it
takes them a little while
to recognize that, and
I think when they do,
that it's a really nice
relationship that's formed
and hopefully continues
over the years.